Vincent J Musi:
So our relationship with animals
is constantly evolving.
For the longest time science
could just never accept
what most pet owners know
is that animals think and feel.
But proving that they have
thoughts and emotions
is a lot of what this work
is about.
The question for me next
is really about
over these 10,000 years
how does an animal
that's intended
for the dining room,
how does it go
to the living room?
( applause )
Vincent J Musi:
Thank you, you're very kind.
It all started for me
when I bought a haunted house.
(laughter)
It's true. That's what
the neighbors told me,
but it was after
I bought the house.
Here's a photograph of it.
(laughter)
The previous tenants
had heard all this scratching
and kicking and rumbling and
creaking all around the house,
they thought it was
the ghost of Edgar Allan Poe,
who lived in the neighborhood,
where I live now.
So I did what any sane person
would do, I called an exorcist.
His name was Mike Hughes.
And he's a trapper
and a specialist
in nuisance wildlife.
So, he managed to get
all the ghosts out of my house,
the squirrels, the opossums,
the nine raccoons,
the birds, the rats.
It was either that or
to designate
it a national wildlife refuge.
(laughter)
Now Mike had quite a menagerie
at his own home
and I was curious,
so I photographed him.
And some of his animals
were opossums,
an albino raccoon,
and this iguana.
So I asked around
some of my colleagues.
A lot of the guys do this.
We're trying to do this
eye contact thing, it's simple.
We bring an animal,
we put it on a seamless.
I said, "What do we do?"
And they said,
"You know, all animals
are food motivated.
All you have to do
is really kinda provide
the set and this is
going to work out for you.
I thought, okay, that's cool.
Well, mistakes were made.
(audience roaring
with laughter)
Yeah.
The idea here was
to photograph these--
(audience laughter)
Yeah, exactly, these superstars
of the animal cognition.
These are famous animals.
Years of research
had been done with them.
Books had been
written about them,
scientific careers...
And I was going to become
the Annie Leibovitz
of animal photographs.
(laughter)
And it was going to be all about
eye contact and lighting. Right?
Well, it's hard to do that when
an animal won't look at you.
(laughter)
And with some animals,
like this lemur,
every time I picked up
the camera, boom! He was gone.
He'd shoot away.
And my career, like the lemur,
was vanishing
before my eyes.
(laughter)
You don't get
a lot of second chances.
And I thought,
why is this happening?
Why am I being punished here?
What have I done wrong?
I went all the way to Austria
to photograph this Marmoset.
His name is Momo.
He's really smart.
Okay, big deal.
And he smells really bad.
(laughter)
And his head
is the size of a walnut.
And he hates me.
(laughter)
See, it looks calm to you,
doesn't it?
No, it's not.
(audience roaring
with laughter)
He's peeing on me.
(laughter)
He's peeing on my equipment,
and he's telling his
Marmoset friends to pee on me
and pee on my equipment.
(laughter)
And he screamed at me
and he wouldn't stop.
And he told his friends
to scream at me.
And... I began to think that
even fish were screaming at me
from under water.
This is a Gunnison's
prairie dog, and he
screamed at me too.
Scientists believe these guys
have language ability,
sophisticated stuff, right.
It's not like,
"Aah! Bad things
are happening...
It's like, "There's a guy
from National Geographic
and he's gonna come here
and take our picture."
This guy screamed at me
on the phone.
(laughter)
And, he... he's a rescued
prairie dog from Phoenix.
He was hit by a car and
his name is Speed-bump.
(laughter)
And he lives in Wabash, Indiana.
It's like I didn't know what to
do, I couldn't take it anymore.
I started to scream at him,
back at him.
And I started to interview him
like... like a press conference,
rapid fire. "Mr. Bump,
how are the winters in Wabash?
What do you think?"
All this kind of stuff,
and I sang to him.
I did everything I could,
and all of a sudden
he just stopped.
(audience roaring
with laughter)
So, you see, with Speed-bump,
I discovered
my inner Doctor Dolittle
and I embarked
on this new career,
if I could just talk
to the animals.
Show this respect and patience,
things I didn't have much of
to be honest with you,
I might find
what I was looking for.
Now, this is Kanzi.
He was a real test for sure.
Does anybody know Kanzi,
he's a Bonobo.
He's a pygmy chimpanzee.
He understands
about 3,000 spoken words.
It's incredible.
So, now he communicates
with humans
using this vocabulary
that's drawn
from like 350 symbols.
It's lexigrams.
And, they're printed
on a sort of like, uh,
place mat,
laminated thing.
He walks around with it and
he makes complex sentences.
"Kanzi wants this now
with this person there."
It's not like... pointing
to the thing.
And the lexigram for an orange
may not look like an orange.
It's real sophisticated stuff.
So, I got there and they said,
"What... what... what have you
brought for Kanzi?" I said,
"I didn't bring anything.
I brought my lights."
So, we have to ask
his permission.
And we have to ask
him what he'd like.
And so they, you know...
(does hand movements)
And Kanzi...
And, they interpreted
that as "Kanzi would like
Starbucks coffee for he
and his Bonobo friends."
(audience roaring
with laughter)
And so I had to send
my assistant back
into town to get six grande
coffees with the simple syrup,
for him and his Bonobo friends.
And, Kanzi every once
in a while,
will do this sort of thing
where he'll go...
(does hand movements)
And two grown-ups will chase
each other through the halls.
And it's his entertainment.
We're around
for entertainment.
Now you'll notice that he never
really quite looked at me.
And it was intentional.
No matter what I did,
I could never get him
to make eye contact.
He is a very, very cool guy
and very, very sharp.
And I'm glad to have gone
and done it.
On the other extreme
of this, this is Whack.
She's a New Caledonian Crow,
lives in Oxford, England.
When she's not trying to poke
the eyes out of visiting
National Geographic
photographers,
which she did for two days,
she excels at problem solving.
Creating tools from materials
she's never seen before,
to solve problems she's
never been presented before.
An example is,
they would take a test-tube and
put something that she wanted
at the bottom of it, food.
And present her with things
that you could make tools from.
Now, what they didn't
know to this point,
was that these animals
can make tools,
which is different than
using tools.
Chimps do this, humans do this,
very few animals
possess this capability.
And Whack could
take something and
fashion a tool from it to
reach into the test-tube
and get the thing out of it,
that you were looking for
from something she'd never
been presented before.
It's amazing stuff.
Now, this is Betsy.
Betsy is so famous that
that's not even her real name.
(laughter)
I'm not kidding. She's a
Border Collie living in Vienna.
And she has the vocabulary
of a toddler.
She can hear a word
once or twice,
and know that
it means something.
She can link photographs with
an object in the photograph.
An example would be to show her
a photograph of a teddy bear.
Let's say it's Randy, right.
And say, "Go find Randy."
And send her into another room
full of these stuffed animals.
She'll look around and
she's got-- she's pretty good,
and she'll find the thing
in the photograph,
bring it back to you.
Two or three times, come back
in six months,
she's got it locked in.
It... It's an incredible thing.
We put Shanti here, she's a
9,000-pound Asian elephant,
we put her on an enormous
white seamless background.
You know, they are amongst
the most intelligent animals,
they grieve, mimic behavior,
they have language abilities,
memory.
But then they look in
the mirror, they see themselves.
And it's a rare cognitive
accomplishment, that
we know is only shared
by great apes
and dolphins and some humans.
(audience roaring
with laughter)
At the Bronx Zoo, elephants
were put in front of mirrors.
And at first they treated
the mirror as an object
as you might imagine.
But then, they started
to check themselves out.
They'd lift their trunks and
they would look at things
and different places.
See, for the longest time
science could just never accept
what most pet owners know,
is that animals think and feel.
But proving, proving that they
have thoughts and emotions
is a lot of what
this work is about.
And the scientists can
consider this a collaboration
between them and the animals.
Their work teaches us about
the boundaries of humanity.
It's really exciting stuff but
it's about these characteristics
that are distinctly human
and things that aren't.
This is a lemur at Duke.
His name is Aristides, and
they used to think these
guys were not so smart.
They are primates but
they are on the lower end.
But he learns
like a toddler does.
He is learning how to count.
He uses a touch screen
with his nose.
And all this stuff is
food rewards, right?
So you do this right,
the sequence...
you get something,
but they, they have
great enthusiasm for it,
so they don't need to be fed.
They just like to do it.
And rats, they may or may
not have a sense of humor,
but they laugh.
There's a guy at Bowling Green,
his name is Jaak Panksepp.
And they call him
the rat tickler.
He takes rats, and
he tickles them, and they laugh.
(laughter)
So, they are trying to figure...
They play jokes
on each other and stuff.
And there's not a day
that goes by
we don't learn something
about honey bees, right.
They are really,
highly evolved socially,
and they have
this complex behavior
of communication and navigation.
They learn colors and scents.
And they can map
their environment out.
All with a brain
the size of a milligram.
It's a little, tiny thing.
And, and now according
to some work we think--
we find out
they might have emotions.
They might possess
pessi-- pessimism.
This is a Scrub Jay
called Psychobird.
(laughter)
And they plan for the future.
They take these birds, and
when they go to sleep at night.
And wake up
in two different rooms.
And in one room, in the morning
they feed them breakfast.
And in the other room,
they don't.
And after a while they give them
the option to feed at night.
And what they do, is they do
this thing called caching.
They take food, put it
in their mouth, they hide it.
And then they can hide it
in a certain place,
and come back
and get it later.
These birds all hid it
in the room
that didn't have food
in the morning.
Because they didn't know
if they were going to wake
up in that room.
Now the caching thing is
extraordinary because they--
he is caching right now, right.
And every time
I am not looking at him,
he'll go (imitates vomiting)
and spit it out.
Because he's afraid I'm gonna
know where he is hiding it.
So, they'll hide it
and then if they think
they have been seen hiding it,
they'll be like sneaky and
they'll hide it somewhere else.
And, you know, chimps are
out closest relatives, right.
We got 99 percent of the same
DNA with these guys.
We've studied them
for a very long time,
since the 50's right.
Jane Goodall, and
they make tools...
These guys, they love
and trust, they have morals,
they fight, they forgive, they
cooperate, they have culture.
And they have these
unique ways of doing things.
Problem solving,
social responsibility...
And it's all spread
by learning, mostly by women.
Females, like
Georgia here, will pass
these culture traditions,
cultural traditions
on to the other chimps,
and keep this thing going.
These are cichlids
and they are really crazy.
They have this thing called
transitive inference, right,
and it's the same kind of
logical reasoning that we use
when we go into a bar.
And we don't pick a fight
with the tallest guy in the bar.
And these fish, in order to get
ahead in their social rank,
need to keep fighting.
So they fight a fish,
they get their colors,
they get ahead
in social standing,
then start fighting again.
But they know not to pick
a fight with the wrong guy.
And it's this, like step on
the way to logical reasoning
for a fish.
Sheep have facial recognition.
They recognize faces
of other sheep,
up to 50 of them
for like two years.
And up to ten humans
for two years. It's amazing.
This is Azy,
he's a magnificent animal.
He comes into the room
and he's--
Well, that's actually life-size.
(laughter)
Orangutans above
all the great apes,
find-- they are contemplative.
They make choices that are
logical and they're thoughtful,
maybe more than chimpanzees.
This is a Pacific Giant Octopus.
They have personalities,
they use tools,
they recognize individuals,
and they play.
David Liittschwager
whose photographs grace
the side of the building here
told me this story.
He said
at the Monterey Aquarium once
he was doing a tour
with an entourage
that included the Dalai Lama,
who was dressed in his robe.
And they pass
the Giant Octopus who is,
as they often are,
way in the back of their tank
and he was a mottled tan.
And the octopus saw the
Dalai Lama come through the room
and leaped
to the front of the tank,
put itself on the edge
of the tank
and changed to the color
of the Dalai Lama's robe.
They are pretty sneaky.
In Seattle, they had
these guys and at night
they'd block the air pressure
and they'd blow
the tops of their tanks.
They'd sneak off into
the other exhibits
eat the other fish,
go back to their tanks
leaving a trail of water and go,
"Hey man, I didn't see nothing."
(audience roaring
with laughter)
This is Alex.
Alex could use a 100 words
and he had the intelligence
of a 5-year old.
He could count to seven.
He knew 'same' from 'different'.
He knew 'larger' from 'smaller'.
He would talk to you.
"Would you tickle me?"
(imitating parrot)
(laughter)
And I said,
"Sure. Show me where."
And he put down his head,
and he lifted the feathers
up on the crook of his neck.
And so I tickled him.
And then he said, "Could
you tickle me on the chair?"
And we went
and sat on the chair.
And we had
this delightful afternoon.
(audience roaring
with laughter)
It's true.
He passed away at 31,
which is young for a parrot.
And when he died, his obituary
was in the New York Times.
That's how famous he was.
It's true.
So our relationship with animals
is constantly evolving.
It... It's a really fascinating
thing to me, and
probably the single
most important part of this
is domestication, right.
Millions of animals
on the planet, right.
There's like 14 large mammals
that have been domesticated.
Nobody knows why,
nobody knows how.
All dogs come from wolves.
And as a result
of all of this evolving
over the years,
dogs are changing.
It's because domestication
didn't just happen,
it's still going on.
So, these researchers at Duke
are telling this dog
that there is food under
both of those cups,
and there isn't.
So one of them tells the truth
all the time,
one of them doesn't.
And the dog is figuring out
which one is telling the truth.
And then they mix it up.
It's an amazing thing.
So you have these things
that happen to an animal,
once we've domesticated it,
right.
But across the board
what we've done is lost
all the wild animals.
There are no
wild cows anymore, right.
Wild aurochs were the
originals, right?
So we've lost all of that.
And, we have only a few
animals that can go back.
So, pigs can go back
and be feral. Cats can do it.
We think now that the cats
may not be really domesticated.
They just might be
tolerating us.
(laughter)
It's true. They chose humans.
So, the question
for me next is really about
over this 10,000 years,
how does an animal that's
intended for the dining room,
how does it go
to the living room?
(laughter)
This is a pot-bellied pig that
lives in Saint Paul, Minnesota.
Her name is Daisy Mae
and she is blind.
And when the owners
got it, they almost had
to get rid of her
because there was a law
in the books that said,
you know, cougars, lions,
pot-bellied pigs were
vicious animals.
And so they changed laws
because of this pig.
It's pretty cool.
This whole idea of exotic pets
is kinda hot button,
everybody is a
little bit conversant in it,
We always see something
on the news about it.
I wanted to do a piece
on the relationship humans
had with these animals.
What possessed somebody
to want to have one.
I didn't want to judge 'em,
I wanted to give their
piece, so--
It's a capybara going for
his afternoon swim in Texas.
He's a jumbo rat,
130-pound rodent.
A pretty cool guy.
And this is one of my favorite
of all times.
That's Dillie.
She is beautiful, isn't she?
(laughter)
Born in 2004.
So, an Amish breeder
who had an animal
that was gonna probably die.
And in the middle of the night,
he called up his local
veterinarian, Melanie Butera,
and he sort of got somebody
to drive him to her
and Melanie took care of this
animal, brought it back to life.
Over a long period of time.
And now Dillie lives
in her house.
This is on the second
floor of a house.
She goes to the bathroom
in the kitchen on towels,
eats spaghetti from a plate,
goes up and down the
set of stairs.
And she is
the most wonderful animal,
I've ever been around.
She really is extraordinary.
And, you know,
she has her own webcam.
You guys probably have that.
(laughter)
There was a point there where
she got a little freaked out
because somebody came by
with that Burt's Bees stuff,
and she thought it was a bee
and so she was afraid.
And so, she slept on
the floor in a different place.
She wasn't visible
on the webcam.
This webcam has a million
unique visitors per month.
And Melanie got emails
from the International
Space Station saying,
'Where is the deer?"
(audience roaring
with laughter)
This is Albert.
Yeah, this is his bedroom.
Yup, and this is
a 12-foot Burmese python.
Now, he's holding
that python for me.
I'm going to come clean
with you on that,
because his room is full of
every one of the most poisonous,
venomous, aggressive snakes
on Earth, are all there.
So he's got these
Egyptian Cobras and King Cobras
and Australian Browns,
and on every one of--
Looks like the Museum of Natural
History in there, doesn't it?
And every one of those cages,
these things has
a little thing on it listing
what the animal is, and
what the anti-venom is.
And on the door,
is a list of directions
to the hospital
that has the anti-venom.
Because he's
been bitten 100 times.
And so he's like, "You want me
to bring the King Cobra out?"
No, I don't!
(audience roaring
with laughter)
He feeds, he single-handedly
figured out
how to deal with this invasive
species thing in Florida.
He feeds smaller pythons
to the cobras.
Chops them up gives them
to the cobras, "Here you go."
Not this one, but he did that.
One thing I should
tell you is that
none of these animals
are truly wild.
These are captive born animals
and they've been very,
very far away from
any wild bloodlines.
They can't go back to the wild,
because they never came
from the wild.
Melanie Typaldos has
this big capybara.
And she is home every day.
He goes for his swim at four,
and she'll feed him in the pool.
And his name is Gary,
which is short
for Garibaldi Rous.
R-O-U-S Rodent Of Unusual Size.
(audience roaring
with laughter)
He's a 120-pounds,
and he's three years old.
And this is her second one.
And this is not an animal
that takes,
well, kindly, to humans, right.
You have to earn trust
with this thing
and they have an incredible
relationship and
Mario Enfante and
his cougar, Sasha.
This is his child.
I went down, I gotta tell you,
I saw it and it was a real bond.
It was not like
a trophy for this guy.
Because nobody is going
to find him, you know.
Really, really an
interesting situation.
Now that's cute, a little cat.
That's a bobcat.
Six weeks old, it's going to
grow up to be a big bobcat.
Now, a lot of people
raise these things.
They have a huge human imprint
on them when they're little.
So that, hopefully,
when they get to be bigger,
and they go off with somebody,
that they'll retain that
and they may not chew
their face off, kinda thing.
It could be very dangerous
with these animals.
I don't want to understate that.
But, you know, she raises
them, they follow her
around the kitchen,
she has him around her dog.
And it's-- at this point
where this whole process starts.
Some breeders are great,
some breeders are bad,
and there's a whole cycle
that can go after this,
because what are you gonna do?
If it gets too big to handle,
people don't know
what to do with these animals.
It's across the board
with big cats and bears
and things like that,
as you'll see.
This is Mike Stapleton,
he's in Ohio.
He has six, five, six tigers.
And he is suing the state
because they've decided that
they're going to take all
these laws back a little bit.
And you're not going
to be allowed to have
one of these animals
without huge bonds. So,
these are all rescued animals.
These were probably photo
tigers, when they were cubs.
People had their
picture made with them.
Then they get too big.
And at a year, they go
somewhere else and
they are down this path.
Where are they gonna
go, they are not going
to go to a zoo.
Zoo's won't take them,
They don't have room for them.
There are only so many refuges.
It's pretty tight.
The one wild animal
I did photograph...
This is actually
a real nuisance gator.
And the guy
with it is Bob Freer.
He got his first alligator
when he was six.
His dad stopped
at some roadside place,
bought him a gator,
threw it in the back, and said,
"Here you go."
(laughter)
And so he-- he's spent
his entire life now.
He's got this place called
Everglades outpost
and he rehabilitates wildlife.
'Cause lots of crazy stuff comes
into Miami International Airport
and he's got, like, snow monkeys
there, and he's got bears.
But he loves gators
ever since he was a kid,
and so he wrestles gators.
He's been an alligator
wrestler for 30 years.
I asked the man, "What's the
relationship with a gator like?
What do they want?" He said,
"They want to be left alone."
(laughter)
So, you know, I don't know
what an exotic animal owner
looks like.
I thought, what if we took
the same animal
and we did different owners.
So this is at a thing called
Skunk Fest that was in Ohio too.
And we photographed,
you know a little cross section
of some of the owners of skunks.
This is Travis and
he's a DJ at a strip club.
And Nicki is a mother of two.
She's got a skunk.
And this is Malena. She's 16,
and she dresses up like skunks.
(laughter)
And then you've got Maggie,
she's 12, on the left.
And Sean's, a technical
engineer, with his skunk.
And Cherie's, a housewife
in Pennsylvania, with her skunk.
But I can tell you honestly
the bond is true.
I want to leave you
with something--
A lot of what these animals
have taught me is patience.
You need it, 'cause you
can't make an animal do
what you want it to do.
So we photographed a hedgehog
for the cover in December.
And, you know,
like the little Gunnison,
you know,
I could yell at him.
When you do that to a hedgehog.
it turns into a pinecone.
And so, any slightest movement
and the thing goes back
into a pinecone.
So this fellow
Brandon Harley is a kid
who raises these guys.
We took nine hedgehogs
and spent a day
photographing them
on a seamless
to try to make a picture.
And this is a little piece
on what we did.
(rock 'n roll guitar music)
Thank you.
(applause)
That's all I've got.
(laughs)
(applause)